- I know Kevin loves the
Philadelphia Eagles football team.
- [Kevin] Yes.
- First of all,
I know this because my nanny is obsessed
with the Philadelphia football team.
- Yes.
- She's one who told me.
- We all saw him on the field,
after they won the Super Bowl.
- [Kevin] Yes!
- [Kelly] We have some photos.
- [Kevin] Well.
- [Kelly] There's one player
celebrating with the trophy.
And another, oh!
(audience laughs)
And here's where you are.
- [Kevin] Yeah, yeah, yep.
- Security would not let you up. (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- That was it, well I have a surprise.
- I remember that.
- Do you wanna know what?
I have a surprise.
The eagles wanted to make it up to you.
- What do they do?
- [Kelly] Well, it's through those doors,
right up there, can we bring it out?
- [Kevin] Okay.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- [Kevin] Oh, man, awe!
Man
(lively music)
Man!
Yeah!
- So, for everybody that
doesn't know, this is Swoop,
the mascot of the Philadelphia Eagles.
(crowd cheers)
- Good friend of mine.
- Exactly.
- Really good friend of mine.
- And while Swoop can't talk
because, you know, he is an eagle.
He came all the way from Philly,
to bring Kevin Super Bowl cuff links
and commemorative confetti
- Oh man!
- [Kelly] from the post game celebrations.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- Come on, Swoop!
Come on!
- But that's not all
- What else?
- Swoop's friends also sent
along a message for Kevin.
Take a look.
- [Kevin] Let me see.
- Hey Kevin, it's Brandon Graham
with the Philadelphia Eagles.
Just want to let you know
that we are over here,
thinking about you.
And we hope that you're feeling better.
(audience awws)
After we heard you was
going on Kelly's show,
we knew we had to do something.
So I sent my man Swoop
over to surprise you.
- Oh
- We know how big of a Eagles fan you are.
- Yes, sir.
- So we sent you a full uniform
that you can wear on game days.
- Oh my god
- By the way, I hope it fits.
- Let me see.
- We got your measurements
from the wild docks. (laughs)
I hope you're feeling better.
And see you soon.
Hi Kelly. Go birds.
(audience claps and cheers)
- Yeah
- This is sad, but it's
- Hey, this is actual
confetti from the game.
And they signed it, they all signed it.
- The sad part is that, this is my size.
(audience laughs)
I know you guys think
it's a joke, but I'm,
this is really my size.
I'm, this is a great thing.
Hey, I appreciate this, man.
I know it was tough for
you to get down here.
You know what, give me, come on, man.
- Well, he flies, he didn't get
- Give me some man.
Ah, always.